As female gamers continue to struggle to gain acceptance and influence...
...in the traditionally male-dominated gaming world,...
...one dad has taken it upon himself to give his daughter a more balanced virtual experience.
Mike Mika plays a lot of old games with his three-year-old daughter.
After noticing she plays as Princess Toadstool in Super Mario Brothers 2,...
...and was disappointed she was unable to play as the princess in the original arcade Donkey Kong,...
Mike hacked into the ROM, a reconstruction of the original game for PCs...
...and edited the characters so it was Princess Pauline who saved Mario...
...from the barrel tossing clutches of the titular Kong.
Mika has made his hack available for download,...
...hopefully encouraging a new generation of young girl gamers to waste the same countless hours...
...that had made previous generations of young men who they are today.